you have made a promise you have sworn
that you would never and you said this
in interviews I will never drink treat I
will never drink and sweet you've said
that I will never drink and tweet and I
just want to ask you about this tweet
right here get ready do you know we're
going to do because we're going to do
I'm going to give you time to compose an
answer we're gonna take a break more
with Leslie Jones in just a second
Leslie you've had time to compose your
thoughts I asked you the question you
swore you would never drink and tweet
and then this tweet went up I'm drunk
and I want to have sex right now dammit
uh what's going on with that I don't
grown-ass woman yeah and and I sent out
a grown-ass tweet and I expect a
grown-ass answer I think we have one
other tweet let's say look at this tree
right here man I hope I get to have sex
before I leave LA oh no the minute so
scared of me out here
there's the horror here is that
now I wasn't drunk when I tweeted that
no I was sober when I tweeted ok ok that
wasn't a drunk right there yeah it's
just a frustration tweet yeah
now is that true you felt like you came
here to LA yeah what's going on ok this
is what this is what's upsetting me
about this whole Newfane thing you know
I'm saying everybody say that you know
you get the fame you get you know you
get the money and you get the dimin yeah
well I guess women in the other one but
meanness it don't work like that for me
like Collin Michael che all of them get
all kinds of women right you know I'm
saying right I don't get I don't mean I
was completely scared of me
really now what do you think that is you
think they're just in Chatham six feet
tall got big muffin it looked like I
might fight you so here's what I'll pay
here's what I say you said we're the
Warriors that there are men out there
and you gotta you know they're there
whether or not you're not out there
they're not I I mean I mean I just went
out here right here well let me see
there's a guy at whoo okay let me say
the guy raising the roof right there
there's a guy still raising in the roof
okay that guy
what's it like 19:19 boy outbreak you
know mom will be calling me every day
he seems a little yog yeah Seema Lily
okay so what's about this you're looking
for a man right now what kind of got
what do you want in a guy Oh God is okay
um it's like Oh God uh it's a pretty
easy question it's okay it's okay
oh oh okay I can't a I'm seeing someone
okay all right I don't want to dis but
like I don't is a secret so I don't want
everybody bothering him you don't say
you're not talking about that guy up
there are you that's quick
you were quickly about our relationship
we're seeing someone it's kind of secret
we don't know yeah you know I want to
you know and then plus I don't want to
sit on on television and be like oh the
type of man I'm looking forward then I
talk to people like yeah I heard you was
looking for this type of dude they're in
on it but right so I don't want to get
you in trouble dad don't get me in
trouble but I'll do that I will tell you
the type of do that I do like okay I
like a dude that makes me laugh mm-hmm
and it's not hard to make me laugh it
really isn't cuz I like the goofiest
things you like goofy men oh I love
goofy men I love
but seriously I'm serious happy
resurfaced I am I am a married man you
are right not a married man and your
situation was different would I have a
shot and be honest be honest you know
what you're six for you look the other
way he's fixed for ya get six for us I
will consider it you would consider it
yes wait just on height alone and I
don't hide just things I heard about
white boys and you look like he's
specialize in that
[Applause]
so I would use a good deck it mean like
three or four yeah I'm not sure which I
have a feeling they're all true though
[Laughter]
you